why don't we start with just a brief
explanation of what resi does and then
go back to what you apply to I see with
so resi is where a rental marketplace
with the mission to make renting better
we use our technology and we use finance
in order to provide products that allows
us to do that our first product is a
product called upfront which is
essentially a solution that gives
landlords a an option where they're
guaranteed to lease out their vacant
apartments and gives tenants the ability
to lease the lease apartments from us in
under 10 minutes so we when we applied
to icy winter of 2016 we were focused on
the rental space we knew that there had
to be some sort of risk transfer from
the landlord to either us or some other
party but we didn't really candidly have
a great handle on what the model should
be so at the time we were kind of toying
around with the idea of okay well what
if we gave landlords protection from the
downside like if it doesn't doesn't pay
the rent
yeah and to put a finer point on that
the risk transfer has to happen because
that's your value proposition otherwise
no one cares yeah right so a landlord
principally has two risks with a vacant
property a the you know the vacancy risk
itself so the lost income and the
carrying costs from owning that asset
every single day if they're not
generating income that's a loss but then
when they lease the property out to a
tenant you know will the tenant pay the
rent will the tenant damage the unit
will the tenant be you know disruptive
to other tenants who live in the
building these are all considerations
that they have to have and so we we knew
how to we got fairly comfortable to how
to solve that second problem I think
what changed during our time at YC was
we decided to take this next step
forward and solve the first problem so
prior to prior to I see we were you know
we looked a lot like effectively a
software solution that gave you better
due diligence or better screening for
your attendance and I think while while
we were in YC what we realized was okay
what if instead of saying to the
landlord hey if you use our our tool
you'll have a better success rate with
screening tenants what if we said to the
landlord okay you never have to worry
about a vacant unit ever again
right yeah yeah and you know would that
be compelling enough of solution that
you know you can make a business out of
it and you know completely candidly we
got to YC January 4th I told the team I
wanted to you know pivot the strategy
probably on January 6th and we went to
office hours got it told them hey yeah
you know what you let us in for the
thing you let us in we're not gonna do
that anymore we try to figure out what
we want to do and I'd say by the end of
the month we had you know decided on
this strategy and they actually closed
our first transaction at the end of the
month ok so it was a whirlwind jam and
we got a we got to go into the financing
in particular but what was a particular
relative elation that you had you like
shift yeah it was it was how big of a
problem can we solve yeah so you know
there's I think everyone in any way
anyone in leasing and anyone in the
rental space is familiar with the
problems and pain points in the leasing
plans you know tenants have terrible
user experience frequently there are
agents whether there be brokers or other
parties who don't have skin in the game
yep so you know the landlord who is
effectively at risk of finding a bad
tenant or not finding a tenant fast
enough and losing money they don't have
a partner who is you know in that same
risk rate right and so those two
problems were pretty apparent and I
think what we the the quote-unquote aha
moment yeah was
what if you can could create a scenario
where for the landlord that risk isn't
existing and if you could if you could
offer that product and you know that B
we knew it'd be enormous ly complex to
offer but if you could you know you have
to solve pricing after self-funding you
have to solve you know technology but if
you could do it could you then
meaningfully improve the tenant
experience where you know tenants have
the ability to lease properties and
minutes versus you know waiting days and
you know sending all of their sensitive
personal information and you know
typically very unsecure ways and did you
have cash on hand in the beginning to
pay these landlords or how did you get
that side of the marketplace yeah so the
first transaction we did we had the you
know we had the YC safe capital we had a
little bit of money that we'd raised
from friends and family but the first
transaction we did I pulled my other two
co-founders aside and I said yeah I'm
gonna probably use 40% of the money we
have on this one d if this doesn't work
yeah guys and that was not an easy
conversation yeah but you know we felt
felt fairly convicted that it was the
right solution yeah you know knock on
wood you know that that went well and
continues to go well right and so for
people who don't understand the product
fully yeah how much cash are you giving
this land is it it's a full year right
so depending on you know depending on a
given transaction it could be anywhere
from Carla 30 to $50,000 okay and that's
happens
grid on a per unit basis okay so on a
portfolio of units if we're in for
instance if we're engaging with a with
the landlord who has like several units
or something that then it can be you
know several hundred thousand dollars
cash or greater and from a tenant side
how do you meaningfully differentiate
yeah so I think user experiences are big
focus share has released two tenants so
I think you look at the leasing process
so I particularly I least in New York
you've been through this you know
leasing an apartment particularly in any
competitive
was a very painful process there's no
standardization on the qualification
criteria you know typically you know if
your brokers not being really responsive
you can have you know missteps with
being able to see the unit or visit the
unit and so we really focus on okay how
do we make this process more efficient
first and foremost we decided to tackle
showings and they said okay can we make
it possible for somebody to schedule a
showing anytime they want and we did
that leveraging our you know concierge
team but after they can see after they
see the property how do we improve the
application process such as it's more
secure and it's better and and really
that's that's where you know the
technology kind of came into play and
kudos to our CTO Hersh who really
thought through I thought that how do we
implement this in a way where a person
can just apply and get a decision you
know fairly instantaneously and so you
know we've been fairly fortunate to be
able to achieve that and so volume
wasn't a critical issue
it was mostly nailing the user
experience for example you know like all
the apartments or a majority of
departments that I looked for when I was
living in New York and out here actually
just Craigslist stuff right yeah and so
you didn't need to have an apartment in
every area in Brooklyn no because we
typically use third party rentals to to
market through no it was really user
experience and making sure we got
pricing right okay and where do you fall
in the pricing spectrum so yeah we're
alive in the Bay Area and in New York at
the moment a typical apartment you know
our price ranges are you know probably
anywhere from 2,000 to maybe on the
upper end six thousand dollars on a
given unit it really depends on you as a
studio one-bedroom two-bedroom etc I
think we're where there's you know a
tremendous amount of value of what we do
is that we are
we are able to provide a fair amount of
insight to our landlords even landlords
who don't end up transacting with us
we're able to provide them a fair amount
of insight on where their units are
likely to transact give them a certain
price because you know the thing is when
you think about the resources that
landlords have to kind of get price
discovery you know the tools are are not
very nuanced and precise they don't
provide the landlord inside ok and into
you know how does my how does my likely
you know executable rent change if I add
stainless steel appliances or not mmm
that's a change if I have a patio or not
or if I have a deck or not and you know
what we've tried to accomplish on the
modeling side without you know our
internal system is can we put a price on
those things can we say to the landlord
okay if you have stainless steel
appliances your rental rate should
increase by fifty seven dollars on that
corner of 72nd and second for a
one-bedroom apartment and so that you
know that research process and you know
developing that sort of pricing I think
at minimum provides landlords with you
know a valuable insight into you know
where the market may be even if they
decide for whatever reason that our
product isn't the right foot okay and so
following in that we had a question from
Twitter from Roberta's to Marcus what
mental frameworks and thought processes
were behind growing the supply side
around landlords doing things that don't
scale in particular yeah I think I think
landlords are probably one of the more
nebulous communities to figure out how
to sell to and I first and foremost will
not pretend that we have fully figured
it out I think we've learned a lot you
know when we started yeah you know
Keenan and I can another one of my
co-founders we essentially in our you
know in our little rental
we were going through I see we
essentially set up a two-man cold
calling operation okay where we is it
would go to Craigslist Zillow and any
other site pick a hundred units and we
just call people mm-hmm and and I think
frankly the willingness to be able to
just just talk to your customer just
like it's just like the funny thing is
is that it's not it's not complicated
it's not it's not fancy it's not using
you know AdWords or you know PR or
anything like that you know and we're
you know we graduated to that stuff
later but I think to start it was like
you know call a thousand landlords and
have 900 of them tell you you know I
will say it more politely than they did
that they're at interest yeah and you
you learn a lot and what are you asking
them yeah so typically we you know we
confirm at that point we confirm do is
the units still vacant first off and
second of all if the unit was still
vacant that we said okay well this is
what we do we will make you an offer to
ran to your apartment we're able to
close in 48 hours we would love to send
somebody out to come and just take a
look and we'll make you an offer and you
know frequently I think we almost a
hundred cent of the time have landlords
who say to us haven't heard of this
before yeah could you explain to me how
it works cuz I think they're they're
fairly curious about the process right
and I think what we're really able to
speak to is the fact that not only we're
gonna provide them that certainty of
execution and and you know give them
that cash in hand but we are fairly
sophisticated in how we approve tenants
although we've meaningfully improved the
tenant experience in many cases our due
diligence process is meaningfully more
robust than the landlord's so they kind
of get this they kind of get this this
best of both worlds where you know they
have the certainty they get the
shop front but they also have now this
you know this entire technology company
that has skin in the game with them yeah
- due diligence these tenants extremely
well and so for the ones that we were
able that the the hundred that stayed
around you know I think that that was
fairly interesting okay and so what
exactly are you doing to screen tenants
yeah so when when a person applies for a
resi a part man you know we're looking
at some of their in their rental history
we look at credit and look at their
income and employment status I think one
of the things I'm probably most proud of
is the fact that what we're not doing
which I think a lot of a lot of tenants
have commented us that they like this
about our process what we're not doing
is evaluating things that don't relate
to whether or not you're going to be a
good tenant and I think the fact that
it's you know an automated and
algorithmic process really reduces the
potential for discrimination reduces the
potential for you know not approving
tenants who are viable and potentially
great time yeah you know I think we we
balance the right line we want to make
sure that you know you've in the past
been a good tenant you have the ability
to pay your rent you your you know your
your background indicates those things
and if we can verify that yeah this is
the land does the landlord have any part
in the final choice no okay so that's
how you avoid the bias yeah okay got you
yeah I've gotten part apartments in
funny ways and you're just like I don't
know they said they thought it was cool
that I worked the onion a long time ago
that's what they thought made me know
and we we hear all types of stories we I
mean we meet tenants who are like you
know
yeah the guy just you know just shook my
hand and just you know like lights like
the way I presented myself I mean and
like listen you know I mean those those
landlords they're great you know the
stories we we hate to hear about yeah
yeah the other sides of that but I think
from our perspective you know we know
that we're taking not only a financial
risk but we're also taking you know the
risk of the type of tenant this person's
gonna be are they gonna be disruptive
are they gonna do they have a history of
yeah not you know being the best member
of that community and so we take that
fairly seriously so we really try to
balance this line between giving a great
experience but also verifying that where
we're screening you know I would say
probably 90% of the cases we're probably
screening better than our landlord
clients would have if they hadn't used
us do you have a ballpark acceptance
rate I think that's not even the right
word probably yeah I know what you mean
it's a little sort of to give you
context because it really does vary by
apartment apartment different I mean we
have apartments that you know will show
it two times a little rent and it'll
only get two leads and then we have
apartments where it'll get forty leads a
day for a month in a moment and so it
really does vary by locations I could
give you an aggregated number but it's
actually not it's not the most correct
so it's actually apartment specific it's
not just like hey I'm gonna sign up and
then I apply it anywhere well so any any
any person who applies for any resi
apartment we don't we don't charge
application fees okay so if you apply
for a resident and you're approved yeah
if you decide that you want to take you
know apartment a instead of the
apartment B you're really able to do
that we don't charge application fees we
don't charge Berger fees so tenants have
a very frictionless process as it
relates to renting the units but yeah
different units they just attract
different types of volume if it's a
three-bedroom versus a studio
you know the right part of New York or
right part of San Francisco you know
you're gonna drive a meaningful
meaningfully different amount of traffic
okay so let's talk about the financing
side because I think this is quite
different from the average YC start out
the average VC back company the standard
path is to you know sell equity in your
company shares whatever that might be
you guys did that but you also raise
debt to finance the leasing of the
apartments explain yeah sure so so we
you know pretty early at the outset
decided that we wanted to be able to
have capital to provide the solution at
scale for our landlord client and we
knew we had to be kind of thoughtful
about that I think a lot of companies
approach that in they kind of think all
right well I raise X amount of dollars
and save so I raise X amount of dollars
in VC capital I got to spend that equity
capital to fund my origination and you
know from our perspective we thought
wouldn't it be better if we
intelligently kind of created a
financing mousetrap because we're
generating a return on these investments
those returns are attractive to
third-party investors can we create a
structure that allows those investors to
earn that return and allows us to use
the money that are invested in our safe
investors gave us you know just to
operate the business and so I think we
were a fairly successful and in doing
that but I also think you know it's it's
sort of the sort of thing that you don't
even know to ask that question unless
you've kind of been on that side of it
you know my backgrounds in financing and
structured products and so I did a lot
of that in my past life and so I think
we we had a little bit of a advantage
and how did you package that product
because like the closest thing I as a
consumer of this I've never worked on
that side is like a REIT you know like
yeah like ok this is kind of real estate
yeah yeah it's a really good comparison
actually so in effect what we what we
did was say okay you know we leased
apartments yeah that creates
a receivable huh is there a way to kind
of put those receivables together and
then raise money from that and that's
essentially what we did I mean REITs
REITs are effectively that with
properties attached right so before you
raise the debt had you standardized what
you expected to return across all of
these units like did you how did
modeling that out even work yeah I think
we we had a fair understanding of what
the market would require so and when I
say that I think whenever you're
thinking about like the returns of your
your asset or your receivable whatever
you're doing yeah at the end of the day
it has to be at a return that's
attractive to investors so you know we
knew you know investors in consumer
receivables tend to like to earn
something in the ballpark of mid-teens
or greater yeah into the 20s returns on
their on their cash flow so we said okay
we probably need to solve to be
somewhere around there or at minimum if
we're gonna be lower than that then you
know we just need to budget for it but I
don't think it's very difficult I think
for particularly the startup founder to
know exactly what you're gonna what the
return is right because you have these
it's effectively two markets there's an
investor market that has its required
return and then there's a product market
that has its potential return and your
hope is that those two are minimum
fairly similar ideally the product one
is a little bit more but I but I think
there's a discovery process there
and I think that we so far have been
fortunate enough to you know you know
provide that solution on both sides but
but that's a pretty important
consideration whenever you're launching
any FinTech company is you know if
you're creating a return that's you know
two percent well you know investors can
go and invest in US Treasuries for two
percent so do they really want to invest
in your thing right yeah which is not a
sure thing
by any means right so what did the
education process look like on both
sides right so like both on the debt
side of like hey we're doing this thing
and then on the venture side of like hey
just so you know there's this death
thing yeah yeah well I think on the on
the debt side I think you know we were
fortunate we had pretty pretty
thoughtful and educated investors there
they're you know I think fairly
sophisticated and also very capable in
getting up the curve on new assets and
so I think that we were we can't really
take all the credit for that I think we
were fortunate in that regard
as related to our to our VC partners I
think whenever they invest in FinTech
whenever they invest in this space I
think they probably one of the biggest
risks that they are worried about is can
this company fund whatever like the
origination that's creating and I think
you know from their perspective the
worst-case scenario is that you know I
gave you five hundred thousand dollars
or a million dollars to you know pay for
salaries and pay for server costs and
you went and lent it out not that not
that that's a bad thing per se but it's
true yeah it's now limited your ability
to do anything else so I think when we
you know and we went to our RBC's we
said pretty clearly where our intent is
not to use the majority of the capital
that we raise from you for funding these
receivables our intent is to you know
create this financing solution that
allows us to do it right so it's not
necessarily it's actually maybe more
attractive
right to the potential I think so when
we go out and raise a kind of later and
so
when asked an interesting question Akash
Jane asked how do you model risk getting
your business model yeah that's I could
probably talk for like an hour on risk
but I would say so our team if we bring
a lot of different sort of types of
expertise to bear mine is in structured
finance my co-founders purely in
commercial real estate no founders
purely in engineering and you know two
of our senior team members ones entire
background is in receivable research and
analysis and the others is on you know
product development and design so I
think you know the one thing that I
would say that we've been fortunate with
is that you know we each kind of know
our strengths you know where were we got
more specifically to this question when
I think about the risk we have so again
it's principally two things right we're
taking vacancy risk we're also taking
the performance risk on the tenant side
you know does the tenant perform in
other words do they pay their rent well
do they pay their rent but also you know
are they you know are they a good tenant
Yeah right because even if they even if
they're not paying even if they are
paying their rent yeah if they create a
scenario where the landlord doesn't want
to work with them anymore work with us
anymore like that that creates a
business risk for us and so I think you
know our process and understanding that
risk has been a kind of a combination of
looking at other types of consumer
receivables and understanding how those
are underwritten as well as you know
kind of testing things and saying okay
well you know we think the timeline for
this particular rental should be X let's
go back and see if that's what actually
happened right so not even like testing
it with a live transaction but just like
seeing you know
kind of back-testing our own models and
saying okay you know our models would
suggest that lease up would happen in 60
days let's look back that it happened in
60 days or sooner or some catch so I
think there's a fair amount of back
testing for us on the pricing side and
on the vacancy side and there's a fair
amount of not necessarily comparable but
other types of consumer receivables that
we can learn from on the on the tenant
due diligence side and so that that's
kind of how we approach understanding
our risk hmm okay and then on the on the
pricing side in particular are you
basically suggesting to the landlord
this is where it ought to be yeah and
that's just how it goes yeah well I mean
we say you know I mean there's no
landlord that we've ever engaged with it
doesn't negotiate they always want to
and we have a you know fair we have a
fair understanding of the amount of room
we have to negotiate but you know we are
fairly transparent with our landlords on
okay you know this is where we're gonna
pay this what we're gonna pay you and
this is where we probably going to
relist it and the reason we're gonna
realistic here is because this is what
we think the right prices okay and I
think again that that information is
valuable you know you take taking
rentals out of the equation for a minute
any asset yeah if you're selling your
car yeah right
and Kelly Blue Book doesn't exist some
of the best way you can have you know an
understanding of where your car is
valued is if somebody else comes and
makes you an offer right and so we try
to be a you know very transparent
partner to our landlords and say look
you know this is what we're gonna pay
you and this is where we're gonna relist
it you know exactly what we're gonna
make from this transaction and we're
telling you why we think why we think
this is the right timeline and yeah we
could have an open and honest
conversation yeah and then that doesn't
put them off no I think actually frankly
you know that transparency is is helpful
because you know this is their asset
right and this is this is you know our
landlords
you know they this is their investment
the managing property is a very
difficult very arduous process and so
it's important that they see us as their
partner yeah you know from our
perspective the biggest value out that
we give to our landlords is that again
we have skin in the game yeah right like
if if we're if we think it's gonna take
three months to lease us up and it takes
four months lease us up like we're gonna
lose money not you Yeah right yeah and
so you know we want to be able to
communicate to them you know
transparently in order to solidify that
trust you know I think it's a fairly
important thing with any business
relationship
mhm and so now do you have just like a
network of people who are essentially
reps for you to interact with these
landlords how are they assigned to like
a rep the whole experience so we have a
sales team um they engage with landlords
at all different levels and I think you
know what's been important for us is is
learning that the market has to teach us
a bit you know real estate is is so wide
and so diverse you know there are
mom-and-pop landlords around one in two
units and there's you know Blackstone
yeah a hundred thousand units and and
there's a huge subset in-between of
people oh you know a hundred units up to
like 10,000 20,000 units and all of them
have different you know pain points and
so I think I think particularly when we
were in YC we were very adamant like
okay it's it's this type of landlord and
I think what we've had to learn is like
okay let's go find out and see you know
who wants the solution and why and you
know try to craft a solution that works
for everyone I think the other thing is
that we we've learned to be a little bit
flexible to really respond to landlords
concerns right because the interesting
thing about it is that if you are able
to solve the problem on the landlord
side
that that the the benefits really
accrued attendance hmm right if
landlords have lower friction if they
have lower risk if they are happier with
their process if they spend less money a
lot of that benefit gets felt by my
tenants who you know are able to have a
faster and more secure application
process but frankly you know often are
able to get much better deals in terms
of their pricing and as it relates to
broker fees as it relates to application
fees and as it relates to the actual
rate itself right and now do you have an
averaged length of a tenant right now I
mean I imagine - your winter 17 - right
now you're just coming up on a year
right so we had a fair amount of
renewals over the last few months and we
in the last quarter yeah I mean
typically we're releasing you know call
it in between one and two years okay
it's pretty standard for New York or San
Francisco same deal
you mentioned learning from the market
what were the other surprises post YC
I'm sure they're about yeah I would say
I think the thing that was probably
surprised the most surprising was
finding out you know when your startup
founder you know you research other
startups and you kind of like try to
understand you know how they solve these
problems in their markets and I think
you know some of the companies that you
you know you would imagine had very
sophisticated mechanisms to like acquire
customers actually just had like regular
sales teams that like yeah and like I
think that was one of the biggest aha
moments where you know interestingly I
think sometimes you get caught up in the
idea of like I have to innovate
everywhere
and I think one of the things that we
learned and you know I want to say
thankfully we learned this now yeah yeah
is that you know what some processes
work because they're the right process
grand so you should just do that you
know you know I think you know we we
learned you know fairly early that you
know if you really want to work with the
landlord and want to get getting
uncomfortable talk to them that there's
not a scenario where you're not gonna
engage with this person like you know
this is particularly it's a mom and pop
landlord like there's an emotional
attachment to this asset you don't
expect them to just like come well come
over and like you know just list it on a
platform that they don't know they're
you know there's at this early stage at
least there's gonna be an education
process I think you know for tenants
you know similarly our experience has
been we give them a and automated
experience in the leasing okay but you
know what there are times where just
even after someone's leased an apartment
just interacting with a person like
giving your customer call and saying hey
you know how did you like your
experience hopefully everything went
well that's sort of like small stuff
that's like not just an automated
response which we do like we have
automated responses we have automated
notifications you know we can't engage
right with you know with every single
time that we have or every single
landlord that we have on a very hands-on
level but we do make the effort to do it
a little bit yeah because we learn and
also you know we I think build a a
customer loyalty there that I think will
play out to be pretty valuable well it's
such a unique angle right like I'm
trying to think of an example where
something that used to be so high touch
it just becomes automated away yeah you
know like imagine imagine the first time
you go in a self-driving taxi mm-hmm and
you're like you just step out and you're
like you're just gone yeah
yeah yeah yeah no I think I think yeah
it's I think what's really exciting
about right now is that we are kind of
participating in a reimagining of a lot
of these yeah you know industries you
know whether it's you know if you take
open door and and home purchasing you
know you take Oscar and health insurance
there are a lot of businesses that the
infrastructure itself that is allowing
these transactions to occur actually
looks very much like the traditional
infrastructure of the past what's
changed is technology's ability to
improve the users experience yeah and I
think that is something for these for us
it's a very exciting thing to be a part
of because we know right twenty years
from now you know two years from now
more and more tenants are going to they
don't want to feel like they're applying
for a mortgage to lease an apartment
they you know the same experience that
they have with you know buying something
on Amazon is the same experience oh they
want to have leasing an apartment and so
we know that if we're providing that
right we're on the right side of history
and similarly for you know for landlords
you know like anyone else there's
actually no other investment that I can
think of where the the investor gives
their asset to someone who has no
downside yeah yeah whether it you know
successful or fails you know real estate
is probably one of those singular places
where you see that happen and I just I
don't think that's something that's
likely to continue you know
landlords are gonna want that
accountability with their real estate
transactions and tenants are going to
want that better user experience and so
I know I know what we do is providing
those things yeah and so given that you
know our bet is on those tenants
remaining true uh-huh and
if they they do then I think we have a
really good chance of being successful
yeah that makes sense
in terms of broader trends even like
you're talking about trends and global
consumer like behavior basically how
they won't purchase stuff on the
apartment level are you noticing like
certain things are just really coming up
and like this is what makes an
attractive apartment yeah well I think I
think a lot of companies are a lot of
companies are of the same mind yeah that
the application process the search
process needs to be elevated it needs to
be more we have more technology less
human beings and so I think there are a
lot of companies that are that are doing
this in some way shape or form I would
also say the other quote-unquote theme
that is fairly powerful right now is
this idea of creating communities
different buildings and I think there
are there are a lot of different
companies that do this you know common I
think there's gonna be called home
that's that's doing that with kind of
common spaces but this idea of create
like using technology but also just
understanding how to engage in a social
level to create communities and
buildings and like the the power of that
effect I think is it's very interesting
it's something that you know I
anticipate we'll have the opportunity to
play a part in as well but I'd say you
know automated process and more
community living in community frameworks
for four different buildings in
neighborhoods both trends that I expect
in the real estate space to continue
into expand in anything on new
construction in terms of in the context
of like what's coming on the market what
seems to be attractive now yeah you know
I think landlords are constantly looking
for for differentiators and so they're
leaning towards yep
more technology inside of your house
right like there there are apartments
there are apartments in New York where
you'll you know they'll give you a year
worth of Netflix they'll give you an
Amazon echo oh you know I think it's
really about just gaining an edge and
getting the apartment marketed at least
yeah I have to continue
okay and are you finding that these
trends are kind of broad across the u.s.
or is it super market specific I where
are you guys mostly right now yeah so
we're in the Bay Area and New York yeah
you know we will potentially be in other
markets over the next call it 12 to 18
months I think those those trends are
common across every market but they're
moving at different speeds okay so I
think New York in particular is very
interesting because of the saturation of
new development yeah has forced a
meaningful increase in the in the
concessions that landlords have to offer
in order to get their units leased and
in lieu of a concession like lowering
the price or in lieu of a concession
like giving away a month free I think a
lot of landlords are thinking okay how
do I better amenitized my unit how do I
give you services how do I give you you
know an uber pass how do I give you
Netflix subscription to you know
accommodate that that you know that
tenants desire and I I think that that's
gonna be a New York's gonna be a place
where that trend moves fairly quickly
mm-hmm because there are buildings and
landlords who are picking up on the fact
that they're you know tenants are
noticing like they're paying attention
to what the leasing experience is and
they're making decisions because of it
right and so I think you know just as
much as getting those stainless steel
appliances manners I think the
experience in leasing out your apartment
matters and I think that they're
starting to realize it and I think that
that's been triggered a lot by the new
construction that that's kinda
on the market so I think New York is
gonna move fairly quickly I think San
Francisco is somewhat similar markets
like like Dallas DC Atlanta are all kind
of in that boat Miami also in that boat
but there are a fair amount of cities in
the kind of the Midwest or Central
Corridor of the US that you know they're
moving in that direction as well but
there's there's still so much potential
return available in those rental markets
that those landlords don't feed they
don't have the same urgency hmm okay and
there are these landlords all in I mean
I guess it's probably location specific
in terms of margins where you see
certain landlords or like doing quite
well and then others are really feeling
the squeeze yeah I think yeah I mean
it's definitely market specific and you
know those that's a long-term trend that
you know metro areas tend to have lower
lower returns on in terms of a rental
basis then then non-metro areas so we've
seen that it'll continue I don't
anticipate that change yeah nothing
changing all right cool so now that
you're like a seasoned wise entrepreneur
what would you have told yourself having
now started a company having now gone
through YC say like three or four years
ago yeah well I think I'm still a fairly
young founder so I think I'm still
learning quite a bit actually
yeah and I think the what I would have
told myself what I kind of continually
tell myself is really be focused on
solving the problem I think once you you
know particular what you raise some
money and you know once your team kind
of expands a little bit there are a lot
of ways to get kind of lost in the
shuffle of running a company versus
committed and focused - you know the
reason why you started the company in
the first place and I think it's it's
it's kind of easy to fall into the trap
of you know you're an entrepreneur or
you're running a start-up for startups
sake or for that sake yeah and I would
say you know I continually told myself
this today and I certainly told myself
then to be hyper focused on how do we
solve the problem and be you know you
can't you can't you know over optimize
your business and over strategize but I
think you have to be willing to iterate
and willing to like learn from what the
market tells you and not fall in love
with you know I created this really cool
fancy thing and you know if nobody is
interested in it then you gotta also be
willing to like throw it to the dustbin
of history as well and so I think just
that commitment to being problem-focused
to you is is definitely something I
would you know certainly continue to
tell myself and I would advise everyone
to kind of think of it that way yeah I
think it's so common especially on the
technical side being like hey look at
this crazy software I made it super fast
yeah it's like all new programming
language I invented it all last night
any show to customer than I had been if
nobody wants it was about yeah yeah okay
and have you now just hired people that
you can delegate to so you can stay
focused on that problem what do you do
yeah I so you know we have expanded our
team you know I talked a little bit
about I think I'm certainly among the
most fortunate founders in that I have a
habit eeeem of very very experienced
people who are also incredibly humble
and willing to get their hands and I am
very acquainted with the fact that that
is extremely rare yeah
I I really tried to supplement
weaknesses so we haven't really expanded
the team as it relates to the debt
financing or securitization financing
side because that's really my expertise
in I don't think we need to we have
expanded the team on the sales side in a
particular on the real estate operation
side because I think we needed to
increase our bandwidth there in order to
be able to engage larger customers but
we also needed to kind of import some
expertise we had to like you know learn
a bit about how how is how is the
standard whether it be broker or
technology company how are they solving
the problem and how can we put our own
spin on that we've kind of been
fortunate on our sales side to it to
really hire some people with some strong
real estate and customer acquisition
expertise
what are your recruiting Pro tips I know
you get these people yeah recruiting is
hard I am aware it is so hard they don't
tell you how hard it is that's the thing
like recruiting particular people were
like great people like it's very
difficult well once you get out of your
friend circle oftentimes yeah I knew
like three or four people we could hire
and just done yeah same here yeah that's
exactly right yeah my my recruiting tip
is if you if you need to hire for a role
at the outset be very specific about
what you need and it's important to know
like what you need is what you want
right I think that sometimes you can get
caught up in the you know optimal like
perfect I'm gonna hire for somebody
who's going to become you know five
years from now potentially like you know
very senior the company in slick you
know as a start-up you're like you know
your life exists in moments like you
know at any given point in time here you
know
you know maybe anywhere from six months
to a year and a half away from not
existing right so I think it's it's very
important to just remain focused on like
achieving your goals
hire to do that and then when you got to
reassess reassess and what about so you
were working a finance job before you
started this company know what kind of
mental process did you have to go
through to like get ready do you quit
your job before you guys went all-in
I had it how'd it go though I was so I
was really fortunate that the company I
was working at with working at prior to
starting the company they were very
supportive and continue to be the you
know there was a great team and you know
I think we remained fairly close so when
we applied to YC I was still working
there okay
and you know I notified them when I
applied and said you know listen this
could be a great opportunity so I might
leave and and they were you know I think
they were really great about being
supportive and being helpful there yeah
so the the process for me went fairly it
was fairly straightforward like we let
them know what we were doing we kind of
mutually agreed upon a time when I was
believe and that's kind of how it ended
but you know one of my co-founders he he
he quit much earlier and you know he was
just working on the company kind of day
in day out and I think that that's the
sort of thing that you know you got to
have a really significant amount of
trust between your co-founding team when
you know different people are in
different life situations and I think it
helped that you know particular for me
and Keenan we've known each other for
you know an excess of a decade we've
been friends for a very long yeah and I
think with with with Hersh we kind of
found somebody that this is so cheesy I
know but it kind of has somebody who's
Sympatico who you know was willing we've
all kind of had this view of we're just
gonna work as hard as possible so we get
and so I don't think you know even when
wind
was working full-time and he hurts me
I'm a part-time I don't think he ever
felt that we weren't contributing our
share because we would just work until
midnight and put in you know 16-hour
weekend's like until we until you shift
it yeah so yeah this is important I mean
it's a super common thing right you're
like oh you're working on a full-time
and you're like the other guy is one
foot out the door like I am me maybe
it's special with YC yeah if you get
into YC then I'll do it all go to
college so we had a great question from
Twitter that I should ask more often so
from Renee and they asked on personal
life how do you manage your well-being
day to day yeah that's a that's a
fantastic question and something that I
am constantly thinking about I don't
think when when we started resi I don't
think I appreciated how much taking care
of yourself impacts your ability to run
the business and it's so important and
so you know I'll answer a couple of ways
so you know
I would say you know physically have
been more recently over the last few
months like trying to take Medicare so
in terms of not only eating exercising
more I'm getting a check I'm trying to
hit at least three times a week if not
get to the job yeah yeah and just like
you know literally put yourself in a
space where like you're not thinking
about anything else like I think the
mental relief from being at the gym is
just valuable but you know I'm a big guy
down like 15 pounds in starting okay
that's amazing
Thank You Man you know I have a lot more
to go but but I'm but I'm happy I'm
happy with the process I would say
outside of the physical side on them in
terms of the mental challenges that you
have I mean being running a start-up is
you engage with like terror and like
your euphoria like all the time
like all the time like I can't think of
any other experience we're like on a
weekly basis you're like think the
world's gonna end and you think you're
on top of the mountain and so I think
having resources around you you know we
have you know a coach who who I talked
to on a regular basis just a kind of
level set and like be able to think
outside of just the tactical day-to-day
but you know and this is gonna be a
little sappy that it's true frankly the
moat the biggest the biggest help to me
on a day-to-day basis is you know my
partner my girlfriend she is I genuinely
don't know how I would do any of this
you know frankly having having her as
you know a person I can talk to and just
download with but also can can help kind
of take me away from the day-to-day that
that's been super helpful for me so I
feel really really fortunate I have a
lot of really supportive people who
understand the amount of effort and time
it takes to run this business and yeah
you know and have been there to be
really supportive hmm until you do you
now block off time to spend time with
them yeah it's it's tough yeah I'll give
you a good example we we we took a
family vacation yeah I didn't really
vacate there about you know I'm still
doing conference calls still checking
emails cuz like a starts your life like
you you you don't you try to like
separate they're like you're it's it's
your baby right I think what I've been
doing a better job of is you know giving
myself blocks of time to our windows
3-hour windows where
I'm generally not gonna yeah and I think
that that's really what I've been
practicing is like every day or so like
after you know maybe after 8 o'clock or
after 9 o'clock like okay I'm not
checking not checking yeah then you know
I wake up at 5:00 every morning and
agree man it's like it I don't think
well not everyone has a problem with
someone wants to work a lot but it's a
person who's like constantly checking
like brushing email fees you yeah you
gotta have you got a you know at the end
of the day you you have to be able to
show that that person's important yeah
and you know that's not that difficult
for me because she's extremely important
to me so I just I'm learning not to be
so much of a workaholic and I think I'm
okay alright so you mentioned working
with a coach and you know obviously
having a tight relationship with your
girlfriend you know super helpful for
managing stress yeah are there any like
books or like I think managing stress is
like a big big issue that people need to
like take seriously in order to not just
be busy like they need to be performant
right they need to like step back and
think like strategically what ought to I
be doing right what how do you frame
that like what do you read what do you
think about yeah I am so I've always
been kind of addicted to activity like I
need to like do something to like keep
my mind and what I really began to begin
to learn over the last year or so is
that's because I had the lot of these
these personal life experiences that I
was really just trying to avoid like
alright you know I'm just gonna keep
busy and these anxieties you know they
can be driven by you know personal life
experiences or experiences of you know
close friends both in my case that
manifest themselves in
you know you being a you know you
working but frequently that working
isn't productive because you're just
doing it to not like pay attention so I
I think first and foremost what I've a
skill that I've only recently learned is
like in the middle of you know having an
anxious moment or in the middle of being
really reached stressed out like
actually just stopping and asking myself
like okay why do I feel this way like
and and I and I mean literally doing it
like I think you know that could be
construed as oh we'll do it in the
moment no I mean literally like stopping
whatever you're doing walking away going
to a private room or station and like
literally saying okay why do I feel like
how I feel and I will tell you that like
I've only been doing that since I
started you know working resi and that
has been so transformative for me
because when you think about starting a
company it's a very stressful thing to
do right like I mean you're putting your
career and your livelihood at risk but
but that's actually not even the most
restful thing the most restful thing is
that you're putting other people's
livelihood at rest that if you're you
know concepts and ideas fail like it's
not just gonna impact you is gonna
impact them and you know these are
people who you know you likely are very
close with and so that's a very
stressful thing to deal with on a
day-to-day basis not to mention anything
else that's happening just in your
personal life cuz your personal life
doesn't go away we start a start-up like
it all still exists and I think the way
at least for me that I've been able to
really get a handle on the stress is
knowing why I'm doing what I'm doing
mm-hmm I think I think there's a lot of
I certainly was one of those people that
I think was kind of just working and
just living the life need out having
like a purpose around it and I think now
one of the things has alleviated a lot
of my stress is that everything I do is
purpose
like I know why I'm running the company
I know why I'm in my relationship I know
why I have the friend group in the
support group that I have and so there
is no part of my life that isn't Purpose
Driven and isn't connected to where I
want to be and that alleviates a lot of
stress because even if even if you know
even if we're wrong even if there's
downside I I know that I've done the
best that I could have because my
interest and my actions are alive right
and so and and that that hasn't come I
really want to I really want to be able
to say like I read this that's where
this came from
and that's not you know fortunately
unfortunates not what happened I had I
think a you know challenging year last
year from not challenging in a negative
way but just a lot of big things happen
yeah I turned 30 last year my mom turned
70 and got older my girlfriend and I got
much closer oh and so it was a very
active year and I think what I've been
fortunate enough to learn is that none
of that stuff is too big for you none of
that stuff is too big for me to do as
long as I'm doing it in a perfect
purpose-driven way like why am i doing
any all of those things and as as soon
as I'm you know very focused on the
reasons why I'm doing it everything else
kind of the stress kind of alleviates
cuz I I know what to do well it also
helps you like cut out the [ __ ]
exactly like this is exactly the things
in my life that like you know aren't
about these things it's like aren't
getting me closer to where I want to be
all these things that they just go away
yeah because I just you don't have time
for them and not even just time you
don't have appetite for them anymore
right and I think that is that's a
fantastic place to be and probably
weirdly I'm I am daily in what pop
probably should be the most stressed
I've ever been and yet I'm daily
probably the happiest
brain you know so well it's not
surprising right because there's
progress so there's a goal and there's a
purpose behind the goal yeah and you're
making progress towards the goal
yeah just like zigzagging around well
totally man but you know what look you
know and you know other than I think the
select few who like launch a product it
becomes the greatest thing known to man
and they you know right off into the
sunset
I think there's everyone kind of goes
through this these periods of iteration
and I think getting used to the fact
that having those moments of this is the
greatest idea anyone's ever thought of
we're you know conquering the world and
then this company's totally gonna fail
we're done we should go it's not gonna
work we have a competitor I should go
pivot to being a beer company which is
definitely an inside joke um we I think
just being able to handle those ups and
downs and keep you know very focused on
the outcome yeah that is a skill that
I've really only learned effectively my
trial by fire but it's been very very
helpful and very very very useful for me
in terms of managing my stress even in
like the most stressful moments I'm able
to kind of level sentence yeah okay this
is what's happening I understand why I'm
freaking out let's focus let's solve it
and you put the purpose into words by
just asking yourself like are you
journaling this down yeah so I I do
journal things down yeah I do that all
the time where I will I have actually
found that in those moments where I'm
taking a step away and again like I said
like physically I'm walking away like
I'll go take a walk or I'll you know
leave leave the room for a minute and
I'll just open up notes on my on my
iPhone and I'll literally just start
saying what I'm feeling and and what
happens is that it just like comes out
comes out comes out comes out and as you
express how you feel you're like the
logical centers of your brain start to
take over and it's like oh that's why I
feel like that
okay fine that's how I get myself rent
whenever I'm worked up I'm just like
right and you think this is silly why do
you care about this yeah generally why
but like you you can't that that that
logical assessment of the situation
can't happen until you get it out right
because you know it like you feel how
you feel
and until you can accept that you feel
how you feel you know you're not able to
you know actually move on from it
and yeah it's uh yeah running a startup
is a very like all-encompassing
experience cuz it's not just the running
the business it's the what it takes from
you as a person to do it
and you know I'm really grateful for the
opportunity to do it because I think
yeah I think it is driven a lot of
personal growth just as much as it will
drive you know a lot of professional
growth yeah man that's great a lot of
wisdom let's just wrap it up there thank
you so much all right thanks
you